hi everybody welcome to Facebook live if
you don't know I'm Norah O'Donnell yes
you are and who are you and I am Gayle
King and who's this guy
introduce yourself guy I'm John
Dickerson so we've just wrapped up like
our first week doing the show yes it was
just announced last week that John
Dickerson is a new co-host of CBS this
morning and so we thought you know other
people put together fancy schmancy
packages we thought let's just go live
and find out who John Dickerson really
is I'm not that interesting material
this is called let it rip face in the
Toyota green yes this morning for people
to know a little bit about you John
Dickerson I'd like to start with this
your middle name
Fredrik favorite color grandfather's
name was Frederick Heydrich Joe but my
mother spelled it wrong on my birth
certificate
put a CH Fredrick but its CK we think
but it's still open the air come on
Frederick Dickerson what's it on your
Social Security card I don't think I
don't know I haven't looked at my social
security card for such a long time okay
good all right okay favorite color
I think it's orange but don't but it but
I don't think that's really true I don't
I think I'm pretty I don't think I have
a super favorite color
this is what I think a lot of people
wanted this job because they wanted the
chance to anchor with Norah O'Donnell
and I would be there too so we had a lot
of gentleman callers and suitors so I
would like to since the mid 18th century
yes we had a lot of doesn't call thank
you sir how big is your dowry I think
that big so the question is is why do
you think that you were qualified to sit
with Norah O'Donnell Norah Morahan
O'Donnell and Gayle Patrice King well no
one what do you bring to the tape no one
is qualified really so it's only people
who can reach a rough approximation
patient and I think the first is self
deprecation again humility no I say all
this to say John I'm really thrilled I
know nor is too I'm not gonna speak for
her but we're very excited okay I know
we are very very excited but the thing
that struck me about it is I a didn't
see it coming number one we had done a
show and Annie we weren't insulted yeah
we
in December where you were filling and
they said no no no it's not an audition
it's not an audition
he's just filling in and I think that
week went so well that a lot of light
bulbs went off for people but I thought
he'll never want this job because he's
enjoying Face the Nation was it a tough
decision for you it was well it's a
really tough decision because I loved
Face the Nation I love down there
Washington's my hometown but I thought a
lot about what we do down there and then
getting to do everything we came up here
and you know you create a world that
you're about to go into full of like
gumdrops in candy and it's all gonna be
wonderful and then reality kicks in but
this last week it's been fantastic the
conversations working with the two of
you both on and off the air the
choreography the banter the
back-and-forth to understanding and
thinking about issues that I wouldn't
have gotten to in my old job so it's the
weird thing where you actually are
exceeding expectations that's when you
already have high expectations you don't
move your family and to a whole new city
and out of your last job unless your
expectations are pretty high and you've
got teenagers and a wife so there had to
be a family discussion about that there
was a family discussion my wife is ready
to move already I'm on the Acela the
kids were a little age 15 and almost 14
and they were mystique for themselves
teenage kids you don't want to speak for
them but they were a little bit cautious
but now they're ready to go good we
should say that we are monitoring some
of your comments and questions so send
them in and we will ask John whatever we
want to know in fact oh the questions
are in Brendan come in so people can see
that you're not just an arm this is who
is taking who is taking all of your
questions Thank You Brandon
okay good all right okay if you weren't
a journalist what other profession would
you work in Oh so the two quite two
answers one is the one I would want to
work in and be good enough to work in
which would be a musician and then what
do you play the guitar okay anything -
no I I do I do sing I sing not in front
of other people mostly but all right
I have done that and then people
survived but it's not it's I'd rather
just play the guitar but I don't know I
think I'd probably be I probably be in
academia probably that's where I was
headed school like a professor I think
yes that would be like or college
president oh I don't know professor
can I just say um we had I had a 75th
birthday party for Bob Schieffer at our
house and John and his wife and his two
kids came and his son and this was four
years ago his son sat down at my piano
my grand piano and played beautifully so
that's obviously a nice trait you've
passed on to your kids is your musical
now well and he's now better then I mean
far better so what happens as we listen
to music and I'm like okay so what key
is that in and then he carries that and
I just kind of follow along after him
and we should say you two have known
each other for a very long time so John
Dickerson isn't new to you and nor is it
new to you
real wasn't that yeah so probably since
I was 23 20 years ago yeah yeah when we
were first and my birthday is next
Tuesday is it really oh you and my
daughter are very close birthdays yes
I'm an Aquarius Gail's Capricorn when's
your birthday sir July July okay yeah
right after the nation's birthday I
think we should also talk about your mom
Nancy Dickerson who was a legend in this
business I I think there's something to
me that feels like a full-circle moment
only in that her picture has been on the
set from the very beginning you know we
put mementos of things that represent a
force for good in this business or
something that we feel are iconic and
your mom has been on our bookshelf since
the very beginning of this show what do
you think she would say about you being
in this job well you know we talked
about this on the first a week ago today
and I do we can talk about it again yeah
yeah yeah you know I just want to
terrified of repeating myself um I think
the very first thing would be I mean you
know she spent eight years trying to get
on air and they kept saying no women and
men in the audience won't take authority
from women so I it's absolutely the case
she would be thrilled and would have
been thrilled at both of your careers in
that I was joining the two of you I
think the other thing is that
I think she would be have a little bit
of amusement probably because we had a
pretty rough relationship when I was a
in high school and then when I got out
of college and so to to see me now
essentially following so closely in her
footsteps she would probably have a wry
a little moment about that
well you said rough relationship I'd
like to know more but I know we don't
have that much time but we had an Curry
on today and I thought it was
interesting that you said during the
break that your mom actually had to
leave the business to sort of forced out
because of her age and I said to John
what was your mom's age and you said we
decided it was 47 46 47 at which point I
started weeping uncontrollably a few
years left yes that wasn't CBS it was a
different right okay can I read Because
Phase II alive I'm looking at some of
the what is your favorite genre of music
one of the questions so I probably folk
roots rock and classic rock ok Jane asks
who will be the new anchor of Face the
Nation Wow that's up to people not in
this room at the moment so it's a great
mystery who would you like to be the new
anchor face nation I'm not going to
answer that question day ok ok but you
don't have an idea no just say you now
witnessed one we have no inside voice do
we ask tough questions have not only
guests at the table but one another
right you know I'm not gonna answer that
question so he knows we have ways of
making you talk oh wait Brandon is oh
come on in Brandon so people can see I
think not just a voice on the side what
is your biggest challenge interviewing
politicians today ah oh you know that's
a great question the biggest challenge
interviewing public that's that question
is the change in the essentially a lack
of shame there used to be a penalty that
politicians paid for saying something
that was either untrue or something that
was a total that was a what I would is a
response instead of an answer so if I
ask you what color is the sky and you
say fast you have responded but you have
not answered and the that because with
the norms that used to keep people in
line you would ask a question they would
answer it now they say something that's
way over here
you have to spend all your time getting
them back into the normal boundaries and
they know that and they use that to eat
up the clock and so trying to have an
actual exchange of information and when
you have somebody on who actually is
anxious to respond with information to
the query you've posed it's it's like a
drink of water in the desert but you
have such a very charming way when
people don't answer a question of
circling back I always used to marvel
when I would watch Face the Nation
watching you when somebody wouldn't
directly answer the question you let
them finish but then you'd circle back
because I find it frustrating when you
ask a politician a question they quite
often have a talking point and no matter
what you ask them they're sticking to
that talking point and your natural
inclination is to kind of react strongly
and I think you know it certainly for
people who are on the other ideological
side or people who are watching want
really to come right at them and in some
instances that's a necessary thing to do
it's the right thing to do in other
cases there are a lot of people watching
who aren't quite sure why you're so
upset at them or they're confused and so
it does sometimes require to get to the
good answer you have to do that but also
just to get people along with you you
have to be a tiny bit more patient than
some people would like Nancy price
you're the next questionnaire on CBS
this morning Facebook live Nancy yes do
you want to do correspondent work now
and if so will it be with a new
perspective well it's definitely the the
show has given me a new perspective I
yeah sure correspondent work I mean I
don't all you know interviews in a sense
our correspondent work but we also have
an amazing group of correspondents it's
fantastic that snot the great thing
about this job you get to pitch to the
correspondent one day there on this side
of the world the other there on this
side of the world and the amazing work
so we have a pretty great group there
well I can't wait to see what happens
dr. Seuss has a book called oh the
places we will go something like that
and I'm thinking that applies to us oh
but I'm really looking forward to it you
see dr. Susan I said dr. Seuss I went to
college let me predict up-up and that
was fun should we do more of these face
book lives way in yes Brennan says yes
more face book lives good discussion bye
guys thanks for joining thank you go
tomorrow